front the crisis which is real on our
southern border as we are learning
tonight
that the biden administration is
continuing to separate
some child migrants from close members
of the family
and what is now a growing wave of
unaccompanied minors at the u.s border
resources are strained
migrant surges are here they are real
it's a real crisis
and what's the biden white house's
response
more deflection more distraction and
more dangerous
border open border policies in other
words amnesty is next let me be clear
what the biden administration is doing
at the border is largely
all self-inflicted biden rolled back
donald trump's remain in mexico policy
that reduced asylum fraud and kept our
borders safe and secure
biden touted a deportation moratorium
biden's rhetoric continues to
incentivize migrants to make a
treacherous journey to the border where
many fall victim
to these ruthless human traffickers and
coyotes and drug smugglers
and yes even covet and joining us now
with reaction former acting
cbp commissioner mark morgan and along
with congressman dan crenshaw who
recently he was at the u.s mexico border
where
he saw firsthand the crisis that is
unfolding right
biden's denying it's a crisis
congressman i see a crisis we've been
reporting on a real crisis
and i didn't mention you know uh
all the the end of catch and release the
promise of amnesty
uh nor did i mention the 185 examples in
the brownsville sector alone of
covet positive tests and that does not
include people today
right so few takeaways from my visit one
absolutely a crisis i was at the border
station in uh
rio grande city it's 6 000 illegal
crossings just last month that's most
they've had in history because
what that's going to actually double
this month there's thousands a day
and it's completely unsustainable turns
out this is really hard see the bite
administration is dealing with that now
it's really hard to process thousands
and thousands of people
it's also very preventable look as you
said on day one biden reversed the
remaining mexico policy this was the
major deterrent to people coming across
look only about ten percent of people uh
asking for asylum have a valid asylum
claim
so when you disincentivize that say hey
okay fine wait and adjudicate your claim
in mexico
well people don't tend to come across
but when you tell them look we're not
going to deport you
might even give you asylum and we're
definitely going to release you give you
a kova test and a bus ticket anywhere
you want
you're going to get a huge influx of
people and now texas is having to foot
the bell
spend hundreds of millions of dollars on
border security because border patrol
now has to be you know taken up doing
processing and humanitarian issues
and actually just introduced a bill
tonight to pay texas back
uh for our border operations over the
last 10 years and mark they stopped
building the border wall almost
immediately greyhound bus operators
they're now demanding covert tests
from people that get on the bus because
i hadn't been tested everybody
nor do i see in detention centers any
social distancing or much mask wearing
and they're not even testing everybody
and yet we are getting lectured by
biden to wear a mask uh even after we're
vaccinated
i haven't been back on the love
look the level of hypocrisy uh just
keeps getting stronger and stronger
every day and representative crenshaw
look
everything he's just said is spot on and
we saw this coming sean
the president said he was he was
absolutely correct
is that they caused this this is a
self-inflicted wound and let me talk to
you
about the lie that they're telling
american people that this isn't a crisis
you're going to see in february a
hundred thousand a hundred thousand in
february
they're you're gonna see they're
averaging between four thousand and five
thousand
a day individuals that they're
apprehending there is no doubt this is a
crisis
and already in the first in the first
five months sean they've operated four
hundred thousand
four hundred thousand trying to
illegally enter the country all of 2020
that for 458 000. we still have seven
months to go
and we've already almost exceeded what
we had in
fy 20. right well okay now
a lot of this to congressman is based on
one thing and that's the promise of
amnesty and a path to amnesty oh
so you're able to vote in three years
how convenient for democrats
is that partly what this is about yeah
look i i don't know how else to read
their intentions at this point
i think democrats used to be with us on
basic border security and basic rule of
law
but now biden basically refuses to do
his duty under the constitution the
constitution says the president is there
to enforce
laws passed by congress well then you
have to enforce section
1325 which says uh it's illegal to cross
the border
look i was down in roma texas and i
could see behind me the rio grande river
and they said every night you're going
to see dozens of rafts come across
all people have to do as long as they
brought a kid with them is walk across
turn themselves into border patrol they
know they're getting a free bus ticket
anywhere they want the u.s
this is completely unsustainable i've
been down there almo
between the rio grande and san diego
about 14 times myself
and i've seen it this former president
trump
fixed it now it's wide open again not
good for the country all right thank you
both when we come